ciao ragazzi ci sono per fortuna solo
sono altrimenti la gente vita che ride
in faccia e lo state chiedendo tutte
allora una volta per tutte tre
ingredienti segnalate veli per la faccia
siero lacrime la mattina a sera fatelo
impianto poi nutritevi delle vostre
stesse tesi e infine dormito con un
limone questa quarantena ci sta portando
verso lidi inesplorati ho deciso di
preparare l'attivita perché vi farò
mettere questo secondo me la meritavo
già adesso la farina modo assolto il
lievito all'interno dell'acqua con 8
grammi di olio extravergine di oliva
fanno perché che cosa succede questo è
quello che stiamo combinando con il
sapiente aiuto di mister vilson io e
mister wilson abbiamo fatto un ottimo
lavoro
[Musica]
allora iniziamo dagli affari il
guanciale io le sto mettendo un botto ma
tu perché lì e posizionati come se
fossero un presepe lo faccio anch'io ti
sistemo proprio nel loro spazio vitale
come viene già uno stesso ragazzi
addosso che non pensavo di poter
possedere dall'aspetto aspetta prende un
piatto con nello scottex era una mia
amichetta come faccio a capire quando è
pronto del guanciale
[Musica]
ok ma è comunque se stato abbastanza
chiaro quindi grosso e nero non lasciare
la padella grasso salve a tutti
benvenuti nella cucina di chef mario
oggi ci accingeremo a fare gli hamburger
fatti in casa per cominciare qua abbiamo
eccezionali panini infatti in casa carne
di buona qualità formaggio cheddar
cipolla che adesso la nostra biglietti
in farà come dice caramellare io sono
uno molto classico con l'hamburger non
faccio quelle alternative alla purga il
classico formaggio un po di verdura
cipolla e chissà dice che ha visto
questa non è cucina buttata quasi ma sul
serio veramente ragazzi si è anche una
sua mano cosa mi vorrebbe insegnare
esattamente ma scusa se poi la ributta
nella puglia che senso ha
cioccolando il guanciale come se fosse
un amante segreto in tempo di guerra
nessuno buttava i tuorli metope perché
le metto un sacco
io mi sfondo di bene
mamma mia con le buste della spesa
calcola anche la consistenza non è
piacevole da vedere quanto emesso che ne
metti un bel po to me non è un problema
cioè come centro a malapena parti non
essere volgare non in live è normale che
diventi verde io sono un po non tonico
allora per prima cosa a beatrice naruto
la padella d'olio giusto che tu ora
vorrei può riscaldare o quanto soltanto
per farle vicinanza
poi io ragazzi caramello con zucchero
acido balsamico finisse
per elaborare questo l'aceto balsamico
qui nel tempo e vapori e avremo il
nostro cipolla caramellata mentre
beatrici na termina il procedimento di
rosolare le patate le varie vabbè
cominciamo a riscaldare la padella
perché tra poco ci buttiamo la carne
cominciamo la preparazione dei panini un
consiglio da esterno non capisco niente
non so veramente poco con sinceramente
facciamo 120 no non ho messo un chilo
mazza ragazze cioè veramente mandereste
in carcere ok potrei avere superato
ok aggiunta fatto una creano pazzesca
guardate che il crema pazzesca questa
porta sfiga non capivo il tracciamento
ho fatto ok devo tenere da parte acqua
di cottura
mancano 4 minuti assaggio vediamo se mi
piace a me piace in realtà così al dente
tanto meglio mangiare io
aspetta la supponendo super bene io non
so qualcosa di girare guancia di ragazzi
con di tissima di camastra
abbiamo messo gli hamburger a cuocere la
cipolla equa il caramellata il pane lo
sto un po il cavallo al forno quasi e
maionese tratteggiato da mamma formaggio
rucola in sala a quante famo paratia
della latina una gara pizzicata e
tecnica di germanio riadatta fuori
panini tour aula negativa che vuole
portarmi a cipolla cibo al schiphol
maionese fatta in casa buonissimo almeno
faremo finta che buonissima un po di
salsa barbecue captata tata pilsen e
insalata fatta tutta e per concludere
rucola ci diamo ho fatto i primi tre
chiaramente noi se ne scorgiamo più di
euro a testa
questo risultato sembrano buoni come ho
detto la mia ricetta e di panini molto
molto semplici allora ragazzi eccoci era
ora di questi panini prego accomodatevi
eccoli qua chi si scoprano i panni di
chef mario guarda il maiale che sei
ragazzi con sono che sta succedendo
bassolino sono i ragazzi di regole cosa
non fare per sentirvi la stanno
piazzando io non so come comportarmi
non so più cucinare non so cucinare
senza qualcuno che mi muri di matematica
calma non fare la pazza non fare la
pazza al tuo sonno attiene la canna in
piazza perché oltre shortest cosa avete
fatto nel frattempo ok posso servirla
[Musica]
non ce la faccio più ad aspettare
voglio semplicemente il vostro via per
metterle mangiar meno
non vi state rendendo conto ma dovette c
parmigiano pecorino di sos confuso
minori mettere quanti più o meno carico
di pecorino ci sto più cafoni le voi io
vengo dalla strada per behrami una
cafonata ragazzi allora purtroppo non
potevo riprendermi mentre facevo gli
ultimi perché i maiali sono lì e stanno
mangiando quindi eccoli qua ma teme la
fa scudo no
la rucola non ho messo mi chiamano
fortuna ora che ho messo la rucola
possiamo definitivamente a chiuderli
rieccoli che magna da parte 2
allora eccomi finalmente posso mangiare
dopo aver sparato questi basta questa è
la mia modesta cena non so se si vede
bene
buon appetito
così fatto siamo riusciti a far male
scusate non secondo accusare il mio un
disabile comunque vuole solo per vedere
lei in cui volo poi vedo una calo fatto
il live adesso una le martina anche la
questione a carbonara più buone mi sono
mai mai fatto guardi la crema
[Musica]
[Applauso]
da qui si chiama ciao
questa era la mia parrocchia dancin anni
possa diventare quella di farli suisse
il gol e portate un tappetino vorrei
comprato va bene il tuo partner ce l'hai
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dobbiamo iniziare col programma ma
iniziare bene su monte piazzo
riscaldamento ginocchia
io posso far suonare il mio partner
forte non so se una sensazione che hanno
anche altre persone che stanno a casa
fatemelo sapere ragazzi cioè io sto
mangiando come un maiale ma sento questa
zona tutta che è come se tira che
solitamente sono attacchi non è esatto e
flaccido invece sento che panna e come
avere un corpetto non so come dirti che
già lo sono
[Musica]
guarda perché siamo sempre collegato
esercizi e in col partner 15 stiamo
scaldando ebbero bisogno tutti quanti di
un partner fate gli auguri a marika
marika tanti auguri
tante io allora allenamento finito
insieme al partner che ormai giace lì
distrutto e devastato domani fisico da
covip avrà un training speciale che è
cool una virus
mi raccomando
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mandiamo linkiamo siamo 2020 grande
giove
sono arrivato in tempo ecco l'albo d'oro
è l'antidoto al copit 19 grazie a questo
tutta l'umanità voglio farvi vedere che
il mister wilson abbia avuta pre parlo
di me io sono a casa da sola e al di là
di questo c'è un altro problema ovvero
il fatto che tecnicamente non siano con
la migliore idea adesso andarsene in
ospedale quindi se voi non mi vedete non
vi sentite sui social per qualche giorno
chiamate la polizia potrei essere
mortale 9 faccio vedere non c'è nessuno
ha visto il capitale il primo ed un
esempio è certo eccolo qua
invece questi ragazzi che persone che
amano settore questo c'è stato in questa
situazione ma è finito non è finita
triplice fischio deve dare anche tu una
benedizione a chi ci segue nonna con una
benedizione a chi ci segue e non sono
degne va bene una preghierina alla
preghiera quelle 0
l'ho già fatto il tesoro ti prego per
tutti i miei cari che pratichi sono
ancora si prega solo ricariche saranno
vincere la liga tempo i file che
imparino a conoscere le persone che sono
molto lontane da te perché non sanno
quello che perdono nel loro cuore e le
loro momenti di sofferenza
sì penso che sia finita la benedizione
[Musica]
la benedizione cliccare qui grazie donna
del prossimo episodio